russland hat nicht so viele länder an
seiner seite
weißrussland belarus und
tschetschenien vielleicht noch die
elitesoldaten von tschetschenen
herrscher ramzan kadyrov stehen im ruf
besonders brutal und skrupellos zu sein
seine eigene circa 80.000 mann starke
paramilitärische einheit sie wurden zu
tausenden über belarus in richtung kiew
entsandt aber so furchteinflößend wie
gedacht scheinen sie zumindest laut
aussage eines russischen militärexperten
gar nicht zu sein bild reporter philipp
potthoff hat mit ihm gesprochen
er gilt als putins bluthund der mann
fürs grobe
tschetscheniens machthaber ramsan
kadyrov
kurz nach kriegsbeginn gibt
tschetschenen chef kadyrov bekannt dass
er seinen todestrieb zur unterstützung
des russischen militärs in die ukraine
schickt die kadir ob sie
eine 80.000 mann starke einheit aus
tschetschenien putin skrupelloses
killerkommando eine kampferprobte horde
ohne gewissen sie kommen um zu morden
jetzt der verdacht wird hier nur verbal
scharf geschossen das ganze nur eine
propagandalüge die furchtlosen kämpfer
nur in social media bild spricht mit dem
russischen militärexperten russland lévy
chef der gruppe konflikt intelligence er
analysiert exklusiv für bild das
vorgehen der kategorie in putins
blutigem angriffskrieg auf die ukraine
seit den ersten tagen sind sie in der
ukraine
allerdings haben wir seit beginn der
operation keine schlacht gesehen an der
die condor soldaten teilgenommen haben
seit den ersten tagen befinden sie sich
im hinterland nehmen videos auf und
versuchen sie lenski ukrainischen
soldaten oder nationalisten ist es
drohen dreimal haben sie selbst etwas
als schlacht bezeichnet das war bei
einer militärbasis der ukrainische
nationalgarde in rostock ihre aber es
ist bekannt dass die militärbasis mehr
war sie sind auf eine leere basis
bekommen haben mit niemandem gekämpft
eine tschetschenische flagge gehisst und
behauptet dass die krasse kämpfer wären
und eine basis eingenommen
auch die unzähligen mobilisierungs
videos in den sozialen netzwerken sind
seiner meinung nach nichts weiter als
heiße luft
nachdem nach einigen tagen klar wurde
dass die kartons soldaten nicht kämpfen
und als soldaten völlig nutzlos sind
haben sie den pr druck erhöht sie haben
also noch mehr videos gedreht auf denen
sie irgendwas beschießen aber es ist nie
klar wohin sie schießen und offen wen
sie schießen man sieht nie einen gegner
unternehmen sie werden auf keinen video
das ramzan kadyrov selbst gepostet hat
ein feind sehen in einem der
bekanntesten videos beschießen sie ein
hochhaus mario pohl am ende des videos
halten sie ein abzeichen des soft
bataillon filmkamera offenbar war der
ganze gegner ist abzeichnen angeblich
sollen nationalisten in dem hochhaus
gewesen sein aber sie zeigen weder die
waffen der angeblichen nationalisten
noch ihre leicht für uns ist klar sie
nehmen auch weiter hinten nicht an den
kämpfen teil sie werden weiterhin
geschont sie versuchen weiterhin den
eindruck zu erwecken dass ihre kasse
soldaten seien obwohl das nicht so ist
selbst in ihren eigenen videos in denen
sich schießend man klar dass sie
keinerlei kampf erfahren sie begehen
gröbsten fehler bei den fragen wer
hinter wem steht und wer wie entdeckt
alles deutet darauf hin dass die
kämpfende truppe völlig nutzlos ist sie
haben keine entsprechende ausbildung
oder vorbereitet sie können keinen krieg
führen das einzige was sie tun können
ist gefangene zu foltern menschen zu
entführen und unbewaffnete zu töten auch
der britische guardian vermutet dass
putins pitbulls bereits zu beginn des
krieges verlustreich gekämpft haben der
enthusiasmus soll immer mehr schwinden
mittlerweile sollen die kämpfer mehr mit
ihren social media accounts beschäftigt
sein als mit der von russland
vorgeschobenen befreiung der ukraine
fakt ist die daten ihrer mobiltelefone
zeigen dass sich die meisten aus putins
stoß druck gar nicht mehr im kampf
befinden sondern 20 kilometer weiter
hinter der front